[Music]
thank you
from Wonder to wonder existence opens
the best fighter is never angry
knowledge is a treasure but practice is
the key to it
to a mind that is still the whole
universe surrenders
those who know do not speak those who
speak do not know
be like water
to understand the limitation of things
desire them
[Music]
be still Stillness reveals the secrets
of Eternity
respond intelligently even to
unintelligent treatment
[Music]
because of a great love one is
courageous
[Music]
an over-sharpened sword cannot last long
[Music]
when you accept yourself the whole world
accepts you
[Music]
sincere words are not fine fine words
are not sincere
[Music]
the way of Heaven is to help not harm
music in the soul can be heard by the
universe
[Music]
who talks more is sooner exhausted
[Music]
as soon as you have made a thought laugh
at it
a bad man is a good man's job
take care with the end as you would with
the beginning
the further one goes the less one knows
when goodness is lost there is morality
to hold you must first open your hand
let go
spring comes and the Grass Grows by
itself
our enemies are not demons but human
beings like ourselves
when you are at one with loss the loss
is experienced willingly
composure is the ruler of instability
with few there is attainment with much
there is confusion
he who knows that enough is enough will
always have enough
there is no greater danger than
underestimating your opponent
do your work then step back
the only path to Serenity
[Music]
if you are untrustworthy people will not
trust you
a good traveler has no fixed plans and
is not intent on arriving
stop thinking and end your problems
[Music]
if you are depressed you are living in
the past
if you are anxious you are living in the
future if you are at peace you are
living in the present
when there is no desire all things are
at peace
he who obtains has little he who
scatters has much
if you want to lead them you must Place
yourself behind them
give evil nothing to oppose and it will
disappear by itself
those who flow as life flows know that
they need no other Force
he who acts spoils he who grasps let's
slip
if you wish to be out front then act as
if you were behind
love is a decision not an emotion
go to the people live with them learn
from them love them
if you do not value rare Treasures you
will stop others from stealing
a scholar who cherishes the love of
comfort is not fit to be deemed a
scholar
[Music]
a man with outward courage dares to die
a man with inner courage dares to live
one who is too insistent on his own
views finds few to agree with him
[Music]
there is a time to live and a time to
die but never to reject the moment
foreign
if you do not change direction
you may end up where you are heading
[Music]
the more laws in order are made
prominent the more thieves and robbers
there will be
if you try to change it you will ruin it
try to hold it and you will lose it
[Music]
time is a created thing to say I don't
have time is like saying I don't want to
[Music]
to attain knowledge add things every day
to attain wisdom remove things every day
[Music]
care about what other people think and
you will always be their prisoner
The Tao is nowhere to be found yet it
nourishes and completes all things
[Music]
manifest plainness Embrace Simplicity
reduce selfishness have few desires
do you have the patience to wait until
the mud settles and the water is clear
when wealth and honors lead to arrogancy
this brings its evil on itself
[Music]
governing a great nation is like cooking
a small fish too much handling will
spoil it
I do not concern myself with gods and
Spirits either good or evil nor do I
serve any
not seeking not expecting she is present
and can Welcome All Things
is it not through her selflessness that
she is able to perfect herself
just remain in the center watching and
then forget that you were there
he who defends with love will be secure
heaven will save him and protect him
with love
[Music]
if the people must ever be fearful of
death then there will always be an
executioner
when pure sincerity forms within it is
outwardly realized in other people's
hearts
the key to growth is the introduction of
higher dimensions of Consciousness into
our awareness
at the center of your being you have the
answer
you know who you are and you know what
you want
[Music]
when men lost their understanding of the
Tau intelligence came along bringing
hypocrisy with it
being deeply loved by someone gives you
strength while loving someone deeply
gives you courage
I have just three things to teach
Simplicity patience compassion
these three are your greatest treasures
kindness and words creates confidence
kindness and thinking creates
profoundness
kindness and giving creates love
[Music]
your own positive future begins in this
moment all you have is right now
every goal is possible from here
[Music]
if lightning is the anger of the Gods
then the gods are concerned mostly about
trees
health is the greatest possession
contentment is the greatest treasure
confidence is the greatest friend
a violent wind does not last for a whole
morning a sudden rain does not last for
the whole day
[Music]
there is no disaster greater than not
being content there is no Misfortune
greater than being covetous
[Music]
the wise man is square but not sharp
honest but not maligning straight but
not severe bright but not dazzling
stop leaving and you will arrive stop
searching and you will see stop running
away and you will be found
fill your bowl to the brim and it will
spill
keep sharpening your knife and it will
blunt
[Music]
if I had just a little bit of wisdom I
should walk the great path and fear only
straying from it
[Music]
to realize that you do not understand is
a virtue not to realize that you do not
understand is a defect
ambition has one heel nailed in well
though she stretches her fingers to
touch the heavens
when you are content to Simply Be
yourself and don't compare or compete
everyone will respect you
the difficult problems in life always
start off being simple
great Affairs always start off being
small
the snow goose need not bathe to make
itself white neither need you do
anything but be yourself
love is of all the passions the
strongest for it attacks simultaneously
the head the heart and the senses
when the student is ready the teacher
will appear
when the student is truly ready the
teacher will disappear
hope and fear are both Phantoms that
arise from thinking of the self
when we don't see the self itself what
do we have to fear
water is the softest thing yet it can
penetrate mountains and Earth
this shows clearly the principle of
softness overcoming hardness
you are controlled by the one who makes
you angry
the reason why the universe is eternal
is that it does not live for itself it
gives life to others as it transforms
[Music]
ordinary men hate solitude but the
master makes use of it embracing his
aloneness realizing he is one with the
whole universe
[Music]
women want a lot of intimacy with the
man they love
do you imagine the universe is agitated
going through the desert at night and
look at the Stars this practice should
answer the question
the softest things in the world overcome
the hardest things in the world through
this I know the advantage of taking no
action
to bear and not to own to act and not
lay claim to do the work and let it go
for just letting it go is what makes it
stay
[Music]
knowing others is intelligence knowing
yourself is true wisdom mastering others
is strength mastering yourself is true
power
foreign